oh yeah
[Music]
yo what's good bro come on to the Hoops
that's great runs right now you're lying
bro who's there yo everybody say what's
up
oh it's lit like that hurry up come now
oh yeah
where's everybody at everybody's coming
right now what you need it sounded like
good runs when you called me oh that was
the first one who says bro the next one
is about to be crazy bro trust me I'm
trusting you are you ready to fight
everybody's about to pull up right now
I'm giving it like 10 more minutes bro
if nobody shows up I'm out bro you can't
wait five minutes two times bro it's
been four hours you're sitting there ten
minutes away four hours ago
just texted me and said hey five minutes
now come on five minutes bro five yo
wake up bro you wanna play one-on-one
until everybody gets here bro I'm out
bro what where do everybody just pulled
up and slit right now
[Applause]
bro come back hurry up bro
yeah
bro you just showed me everybody where
did they go everybody was literally just
here bro you missed it again oh man come
here bro come here yeah what's up
delete my number bro don't ask me to
come move no more